[Music]
and welcome back everybody to a cuckoo
episode of the careful boys where we
have hey that's so nice today hey hey
Jason Chen back again thank you very
much thank you guys we're doing early
branding for your merch yep that's so
nice indirect branding indirect that's
very good I'm going to you know I
noticed that um I'm also wearing a shirt
you notice it yeah I did it oh my God
what kind of shirt is that yeah it's a
shirt that it
says excuse me what the hell's going on
you everybody
wrong yeah Link in the description box
below everyone yeah yeah yeah but I I'm
implying my intention was to imply what
it take two
okay the shirt says fear
everybody everyone every everyone
everyone fear everyone it's like fear
everybody but one one yeah and then
where's where's the link the link is in
the
description Bel did you know that's the
right way you don't say everybody
anybody it's actually anyone everyone
that's the correct grammar wait really
but body feels more endearing I feel
like it's no but then you're not talking
about it's not right okay it's not right
I'm sorry wrong that's wrong so because
you're a master comedian that deserves a
Netflix show and when you get your
Netflix show you have to get the fear
everyone tattoo because you said that to
every said it and then you took on it
consensually I just want to let you I
just want to let everybody know that
anony is not wearing shoes right now
yeah because does it stink does it stink
would it give it to me let me
see put it put it in my mouth that's how
iell I don't know I was walking in the
hot son earlier give it to him give it
to him you're all talk
dude we a masterful comedian good
smelling feet I want to ask this
question and it's Nick who's the
masterful comedian he's the funniest guy
in the room [__] you okay what don't be
sarcastic with me what if anything is
too serious to be joked about say that
one more time what if anything is too
serious to be joked about which I'm sure
we're probably going to joke about it
still my opinions or it just in the
world too serious to joke about this is
the part where you Rift too yeah too
serious to joke about well you should
you probably should I don't think
there's anything too serious to joke
about but there are consequences for not
executing your joke well well what about
the timing like the new thing well I
don't know because you know people will
say the whole incident right now with
Hamas and Israel it's it's you shouldn't
joke about that because the timing right
but there are people who can execute a
funny thing yeah but it's done well yeah
yeah like basson was recently on Pierce
Morgan that [__] was good fun that was
really good and he made uh some jokes
about it but it was like oh that it
wasn't malicious it was like oh that's
funny but you you just brought up the uh
hypocrisy yeah so it's like yeah his
jokes are pointing out a fallacy or
pointing out something that you didn't
think about but I can totally imagine
some like dense woke [__] who
don't get it yeah and they'll be like oh
my God I can't believe you just joked
about this issue you got to take it
seriously but it is different that the
reason why he's joking versus somebody
that just wants to make you laugh like
he's not trying to make you laugh he's
trying to make you realize and that's
like totally different it's very
intelligent yeah the why I think makes a
huge difference with that yeah I think
um nothing should be off limits because
I think comedy is how you heal so yeah
there's times like where people try to
make like like when people try to make
jokes and it's bad then it doesn't
really help with the healing but when
the joke is good it actually I think
helps with the healing and it brings
everyone together more and I was I think
there's like a person who could joke
about it too like because I feel like
he's really close to the situation B him
that he and he has a personal experience
too so it's like his family and things
so I think that's really nice but then
if like I say some stuff it's like why
you say some stuff we we look like we
shouldn't be talking yeah but do you do
you think that if we yeah I think is do
you think somebody could that is outside
of that outside of that um ethnic
background and not having a personal
experience to joke about it and I think
if their perspective is relevant yeah
but if it's like if they're like a
football commentator commenting on
baseball then it's like I don't then it
usually doesn't hit you know how about
how about the concept of like this is
different but like let's say that
there's a kid who as a child they were
kidnapped bunch of horrible stuff
happened to them they grew up to be a
comedian let's just say and now they
have like a whole run of jokes about
that but they're not necessarily telling
it to other people that need to hear it
they're just trying to make other people
laugh about that when it's not something
you ever needed to heal is that bad well
it's his experience right or their
experience yeah I don't to promote like
does the audience notice that that
person they're basically joking about
things that most people would say don't
joke about but they've been through it
but they can do it I think it's good I
think that's I think it's a fair game
audience know that they've been through
it yeah oh well not yeah totally fair
game right yeah yeah it should be right
I think even it's like almost
hypothetical healing for yourself
because you still know like for example
like some of uh Pete Davidson's like 911
jokes about his dad and all that stuff
I'm way on the other side of the coast I
don't know what that [__] felt like or
how people in New York were affected by
that but when he says it and he's able
to laugh about it for some reason I feel
like someone just gave me a hug about
that whole situ situation and I don't
know anything about 911 in New York so
why talking about 911 denying stuff I
have never wait wait can can I that that
brought up a thing that I I was thinking
about don't talk over Jason Jenny please
he's not even talk anymore you literally
just did that I'm a little confused he's
talking over it right now take two take
two he just
nodding I was curious about the you cuz
you said the 9 who said the 9/11 thing I
want to make sure that I don't I'm not
resp for whatever this is it wasn't me
for sure okay so it's Anthony he doesn't
think it happened 100% he fans
definitely know that mainly St Joe he's
like show me the proof a lot yeah okay I
was thinking about the Nagasaki and
Hiroshima the bombing uh oh yeah yeah
sometimes you think about it huh dude
the timing D too soon the [__] no but
it's been a while about it you said
those stupid Japanese they deserve every
piece of nuclear bombing yeah but I
didn't say it though and radi
radioactive poisonings yeah that's what
you said Jason Jenny what about those
two cities yeah
so the the tell us about the dirty Jabs
the 200 but you I know that's why I
could say it oh yeah that's because of
your personal experience so War you
going to say for um to 200,000 people
were died M kaput I shouldn't say died
take two kaput because it's less serious
when you say kaput and then accent too
but nobody but in Japan people were like
oh let's forget about it but right but
then the 911 both are really bad but 911
3,000 people died and then they're like
we'll [__] never forget yeah but why
I I was curious of like why your off
about the never forget are you mad about
that well no not mad about it no
definitely don't forget but also 200,000
but people like so like Japanese people
are like 200,000 let's forget and move
on in America's
3,000 never again a like that yeah but I
want which one do you side more with I
don't don't ask me that question no I
just mean like as a which one do you not
side with
yeah well I don't there's no side I
don't want to how about this how about
this I was asking you guys this I I have
an opinion maybe maybe this could be I
don't even know I'm just exploring but
what if it's
cultural what if Japanese people take
more accountability so they're like that
[__] happened it's my fault dude maybe
we did something yeah D I don't know
trigger that Americans I don't think
ever take accountability so they they
just get punched in the face but they
don't think that maybe we we might have
caused the fight no I think the
Americans is like God damn it those
ragheads they don't like freedom and
they don't like our women they ha us
walking around in bikinis that's why
they want to blow us up but that's also
not those guys' fault cuz that's what
the news tells them they don't like our
freedoms they don't like our way of life
that's why they F they don't they forget
conveniently that from every single
Administration before we've been bombing
the [__] out of all of alqaeda Middle
East and all that and before that the
CIA built Al-Qaeda helped them out
funded them [__] armed them to go
against the Soviets for us so I'm just
like we conveniently forgot all that
right and all of a sudden we fast
forward to they just don't like our
freedom yeah but then also like there's
so many people who Bo every year inside
like people shoot each other or like
people eating each other's face and
they're like yeah but they're just crazy
yeah but then other people do 3,000
they're like that's [__] forget yeah
yeah yeah so what are you trying to say
you're just trying to say that everyone
should forget about all the kaputs no no
no don't forget about it but maybe like
not think about it a lot who's think
about a lot I don't think they think
about I think most people are on only
fans yeah that's true don't think about
it so much think about it a lot don't
think about it every year maybe you
think that's a better SL then never
forget think about it don't think about
it so much then just a shrug like think
about it sometimes but not too many
times so you want to get rid of the no
no don't get rid of it day or the
Memorial Day or because it feels really
hurtful for like everybody too you know
you feel like that like on September 9th
it gets more anxiety September 10th you
get more anxiety and then on like 911
you feel really really I feel people
feel that because people are hurt like
on the thing and people are a little
more like tip toey yeah
and I just feel like I don't know that
because we've never got attack outside
of Pearl Harbor on our own soil that
it's like a big freaking deal where
Japan's like we've been [__] attacked
like for thousands of years this is just
one other big one and we've had other
ones then Mongols try to [__] come
through and I don't know yeah I think
that might be it too I also don't
actually know how Japanese Japanese
people feel about that yeah that's true
well I I I think I mean from my
perspective it's it's
like that was a different Administration
a different Japan that's like how
Germany's like we're not Nazis anymore
that was their mistake that's what they
wanted so but then
yeah did you know that in Germany they
can't even say Nazi oh really yeah I
didn't know I have a friend who's there
and he was like yeah you can't say that
so what did they say them dudes they
they go um the bad guys
oh they go
the they do the whole sign they do they
do the whole sign they they don't do it
big they do a small they do a small like
you know guys like that they whisper it
yeah yeah that's pretty cool what else
can you not joke about right
now or generally generally I think it's
gotten even more taboo like
from pre lockdown lock pre- lockdown we
were able to joke about almost
everything and then during lock lock
down I think everything was like oh you
got to be careful I miss like racist
jokes and all those kind of jokes and
now it's like the birth of care the
that's where the birth of careful boys
came in but then now it's going back to
oh you could joke again I think Asians
don't really joke about Asians like I
try not to because I feel scared that
other Asians would be like why the [__]
did you make us look that does happen
though what's the next Generation called
gen Z I heard they're [__] crazy now
though the next generation of like
influencers I heard they've been saying
the FW n bomb and they're not even black
like I heard it's [__] I heard it's
complet and that's the culture that'll
probably make its way mainstream but I
heard yeah but I heard the next
generation of creators right now are
[__] crazy I that's totally in line
with what happens everything's defiant
of everything swings yeah yeah yeah yeah
cuz I think cool yeah cuz I think us we
we we got the brunt of the censorship
and so we're trying to fight back a
little and then I think there's like the
UTI guys are a little bit be uh but then
the people that make UTI feel old this
new generation I heard they're [__]
crazy I haven't watched any of their
stuff but that's just what I hear they
must they must have brought the Call of
Duty talk into the real world yeah call
Cod Lobby dang CRA ever been called an
nword so much by a 10-year-old wait Did
they really by a white 10-year-old white
10-year-old Call of Duty like chat is
crazy it's not even just Cod it's
anything online where you have kids
gaming and anonymity leag of Legends
League of Legends [__] chat is one of
most that [__] was real life my mom's
mouth has been [__] by a 10-year-old
like 50 times already do you know how
many PE best and boys have [__] my mom
yeah dude yeah Mom in the mouth the [__]
they say is crazy like I'm your [__]
daddy I'm your daddy I [__] your mom
in the mouth and you can hear that their
voice hasn't even gone through puberty
yet it sounds like I'm talking to a
young woman how do you guys feel about
that's so funny to me though it's
[__] hilarious that's why I like it
yeah well clearly somebody thinks it's
harmless because it's never changed
since the start it's never gotten better
they have like advocacy groups that try
to like detect it or they'll be there to
be like you can tell on someone that
says that to you to this advocacy group
and they'll try to find them but there's
no way you're going to find five billion
people that are doing it the same time
yeah good luck also like but that's the
thing like if they're intention isn't I
mean they're angry but at the thing
they're not going to [__] your mom in
the mouth actually no they're just
[__] changing
weapons we bring that back but that's
why like to to people who are so against
or politically correct when you if you
were to shine the light on that they've
never seen that world and I don't think
they they wouldn't even be able to wrap
their minds around how explicit it is
it's the the generation that's crazy wor
[__] you could ever hear yeah and it's
children yeah the worst [__] you could
ever hear and it's kids saying it to
adults I'm shocked yeah this what's
funny it's even better when the adult
starts arguing with a kid like man [__]
you you you're a little kid you're a
little [__] I I'll [__] your mom you
know they go back that kid already won
the [__] that these kids say make Adolf
Hitler's speech sound like a nursery
rhyme if they were in a [__] roast
battle and this guy's like [__] Aryan
race whatever whatever you bring a
[__] 10-year-old on [__] roast
Adolf Hitler to [__] crisp you'll be
like oh [__] to think that Adolf was
just doing a roast battle and the other
guy didn't get to
go these 10-year-old Cod kids [__]
make all the Nazis cry that make them
cry dude yeah but that's like isn't that
that's how it always is symmetrical
logos what the [__] I
know symmetrical logo that's what's
funny about PC it's like when you put
anonymity in the mix it goes out it's
out don't matter comments people making
Finas like it's all the same I wonder
how many like really PC people like
secretively say crazy [__] online that
too that too yeah that too or just in
person with somebody when no one's
around you know what I mean like yep
yeah that's the that's like their
release cuz it's healthy cuz it's fun
you got to get it out yeah that's their
release dude it's like a pastor getting
caught like [__] the whole church you
know so like yeah
it's like I think like all the most
goody tushu [__] out there that
are always getting caught for like the
worst [__] like those anti-gay like
politicians always getting caught in a
airport bathroom jacking the dude off or
something always it's always like that
dude Senator what are you doing now yeah
it's very like I mean it's called
politically correct and then you look at
what did politicians do when they said
everyone's got to wear mask they inside
and they went to parties and there was
photos and videos of them at events
breath during those pictures it's like
that's politics bites politics is
literally just the veneer so it's like
okay I think you could still joke about
anything like you said as long as you're
really good with timing
execution and identity like who you are
if you if you are not good with those
but your intention is to joke do you
still get punished for saying a bad
thing well I guess it depend on it leav
your mouth CU you you just have
it's like you should get you know I
don't think it should be illegal but I
think I think punished is determin on
like so if you're socially stupid enough
to try to execute uh an offensive joke
to an ex-convict and then he slaps you
across the face and you're like why it's
like you're [__] stupid bro that
guy's a cold hearted killer and you took
the [__] risk I think you should get
roasted but not like physically I think
you should think people should be mad at
you but because it makes you try harder
you're like oh okay I missed the mark
like let me the severity of the impact
of your joke should determine the
severity of your punishment but I don't
think you're extremely influential
person and you have millions of kids
that that follow you or something like
that and you make some sort of joke that
it's like it's teaching these people to
you know act the same cuz you have
influence your punishment should reflect
that but if you're making the exact same
joke and nobody listens to you except
you're saying it to like your close
friend you're close friend reprimanding
you is is fine yeah but then nobody
people's going to be so scared of saying
the thing that's why people so scared of
saying anything cuz then well if it's
the wrong thing to say because of you're
like Ryan said like either not an
authentic identity relevance or poor
timing or poor execution then like but
you're an influencer yeah then people
might be influenced if you're if it's
not shown that you're like publicly
ridiculed in some way for making that
mistake right but what if the intention
intention is like the Shane Gillis thing
I don't know that there's two sides of
you know people taking two sides I think
the intention is clearly positive then
the punishment shouldn't be extremely
ter like terrible but you know what I
mean like cuz we were talking about this
yesterday taking intention to account we
still believe in that you know what I
mean intention still whereas like there
was a period of time even during like Co
and stuff like that where it's like
intention isn't the same as action you
can't just have good intentions and do
the wrong thing you know what I mean
which is true and one
but like we're talking about yeah
talking execute well like even if your
intentions are good cuz there's so many
people that have good intentions but
they have horrible follow through and it
and it comes out so wrong and if 90% of
people are like that was stupid fool are
you dumb and they're like well that's
not what I meant I meant to be cool and
it's like but you're autistic and you
[__] can't do anything right when you
come to [__] try to explain something
well to people or whatever yeah like you
don't consider people's feelings cuzz
you just don't [__] think like that
so it's like I don't know man it's it's
it's to me I'm just like just do it and
then whatever how people react you'll
find out that's on you yeah it's also
kind of funny that nobody gets mad at
like let's say that you have a really
good black joke right it's so [__]
good but you're just not black and you
write it for a black guy to say it
shouldn't you still get in trouble
technically cuz it's your joke and you
thought of it but like you had a
different identity perform it so you
don't get in trouble but then the way
that people view everything is like they
blame the person who says it like you
said Jason wrote your set no Jason's
racist you know but Jason is racist
isn't that funny yeah that's like that's
like Neil BR he wrote half of the
Chappelle show yeah but that doesn't it
doesn't happen that way nobody comes
running for the guy that like authored
it you know it's only the person who
says the thing also we're talking about
timing like you you might be joking
around about something that's not
sensitive in that moment and then 10
years later it becomes a really
sensitive thing that that's true yeah
that's weird that's weird but then the
thing is if people don't like [__] it
was like cool when they just said they
didn't like it but then now the
difference is that people react with
tears of rage and they scream it's like
that's the problem the problem is that
you became like little [__] babies
it's like just say you don't like it
that's it but how long is the gap cuz
because you were saying if you say like
a bad thing and then F how what is the
gap like 5 years later if they don't
like it but I feel like it's going to be
like that for forever though I mean
we're always going to say a thing that
the Next Generation don't like there's
always cultural relevance and context
for that time right so like I don't
believe in judging the past with today's
morality because for me like it's so
easy to look back and go duh right but
we're looking at it from a place where
we learned and then we go duh slavery is
wrong like we know now right and then
it's it's like you're you're looking at
the people back then and say if I if I
were that if I were you back then I
would have stood up against it and it's
like no you wouldn't you would have
[__] been benefiting from it too like
you just it's like there's so many
things right now that we're probably not
standing up against that our great
grandchildren are going to go can you
believe to do this [__] and we're like
well we don't [__] know yeah and I
think that's the issu is right now like
people don't have that ability to see
back then that was just normal one year
you think like how long until you're
forgiven like one year like if you say a
crazy thing now and after one year can
you be like I grew I think if they if no
one said anything within a week a week
then [__] it a week a one day one week
wait wait 1 hour to recover you're
saying like if you did yeah no no no cuz
cuz like if you if you said something
stupid immediately you know if it's
stupid or not and you're like why the
[__] did you say that Jason okay but it
doesn't take 2 years to go I can't
believe you said that
Jason
okay what if I you accidentally said
something bad executed a joke right and
we all laugh we're like right right but
then but then two years later but if two
years later I go you know what Jason
I've been thinking two years ago you
made this very insensitive joke and I've
grown since then and I know now that
that joke is so inappropriate is that
what you're talking about
yeah that too like all the things yeah
but but basically he's saying like
people that ask answering for him every
time I think I understood what you're
saying but if you ask him he'll never
[__] explain [__] that's why I'm
doing it for
him cuz I was thinking of Michael
Richards remember how he had that
outburst and he never recovered yeah
till this day Michael Richards from yeah
Kramer from Seinfeld at was it Laugh
Factory that seemed like a mental break
was crazy though that seemed like he
just lost his [__] mind cuz he does
try to like go on stage and then they
just boo him off right like right from
the G yeah never it never uh came back
damn cuz that wasn't really like a joke
that was just like a that's that's the
key right there it's like he was like a
he was like Angry okay but what if yeah
he had a chain of events that made him
said a crazy thing and then immediately
after he's like oh [__] so then what
he's not forgiv did he ever apologize
for it yeah he apologized a ton of times
what if he starts doing like confed at
Friendly comedy but you know what it is
though if Michael Richards had like a
killer [__] 30 minute special or
something then everybody would forgive
him it's true like if he came out with
bangers and just like made fun of all
that [__] everybody would be like
himself like you you talk about Shan
Gillis right yeah like when he got in
trouble for the neuter stuff the the
Asian jokes he called himself out for he
called himself out for he got canceled
whatever everybody was like happy but
then he released a special that was like
a banger and everybody was like dude
this guy is sick like [__]
it's good thing you didn't get SNL you
know they talk to him like that that's
what that's what he needs to do he needs
to even self- produce a special even if
he's filming it in his own room so when
someone does a banger like that and
recovers is it is that mainly people
forgiving them or is that them just
getting new fans that don't even know
that's a combo of both I bet you the
Louis CK fans that like fell off came
back you think so I'm I think what it is
it's like at a restaurant right like hey
here's the [__] steak or whatever
like uh I'm so sorry let me redo it and
here's another one you're like oh that's
the [__] so their Yelp review went
from Two and then they went back erased
it and they made a five okay but how
many how many times how many times what
like what if they bring you the steak
again and then if it's bad again you're
probably not going to trust the third
not going to trust it again yeah Shane
Gillis earned his his comeback [__] you
got to be better than the first this's
already calculating I only got two
chances just tell us what you said and
when you said it
we work from there he has a video out
there that's haunting him he's like how
do I delete it
[Music]
man